okay let me update you on a big big
thing that we are doing I've talked
before about this critical thinking
miniseries that we are going to be
putting out and what this is going to be
is a somewhere in the range of 12 to 15
part miniseries which will address the
various elements of critical thinking
and this is related to the course
syllabus for the class that I taught
last semester at Boston College although
it's separate from taking my long-form
lectures and making those available
that's a later project the critical
thinking mini series will include such
topics as identifying good and bad
arguments understanding logical
fallacies and many many other great
topics initially we decided to tie the
release the production and release of
this miniseries to a patreon donation
goal and we picked 2250 as the number
and the reason that we selected that
number is because this is a lot of work
12 to 15 really highly produced videos
that will make up this miniseries it's a
lot of work we were targeting 2,250
patrons for that and you might say well
hold on Patriot patreon patrons what's
that patreon is a system that you can
look at our page for at patreon.com
slash david pakman show which allows
people to pledge any amount of money
that they want to the program we
launched our patreon page in 2017 sort
of as a direct reaction to YouTube's D
monetization ad pocalypse and we were
well on our way to 20 250 patrons and
you'll see that right now we're only at
1935
what exactly happened well two things
happen number one patreon announced that
they were changing their fee structure
and pushing more of the fee that they
take on to the donor on to you
ultimately they backed off of that
change because it was received so
disastrously and they lost a ton of
money and creators lost a ton of money
they've taken that back but fewer people
ever see the correction right and and a
lot of people don't realize that patreon
has changed their mind about that and
then January 1st happened and on the 1st
of every month
a lot of people's credit and debit cards
have expired and so many of the pledges
usually about 5% will fail so we got
knocked down
all the way to 1935 which puts 2250
patrons pretty far away but I have
really good news for you on this we have
found two sponsors for the miniseries
and we found sponsors I'm not going to
tell you who they are yet but these are
sponsors whose missions align directly
with the teaching of critical thinking
skills and because we are subsidizing
the production of the critical thinking
miniseries with these two sponsorships
we can reduce the target patrons from
2250 to 2100 and you'll see that updated
now at patreon.com slash david pakman
show when we reach 2,100 patrons we will
record edit and upload the multi-part
critical thinking miniseries first to
patrons and eventually for full
distribution we can do this can't we Pat
because we were above 20 100 page oh
yeah late in 2017 then you know the the
fee thing happened and then January 1st
happened but 2,100 I feel like is very
very reasonable
yeah we're 165 away we can do that
especially with this rallying cry I
believe so Oh believe me I'll be crying
later but that's gonna be off-camera but
thanks for bringing that up
we even have and I want to share this
with you we've got an introduction that
was made by producer Noah Ferguson it's
ready to go which we're showing our
television audience I actually believe
that this might be the best sort of
long-form
I guess I'd call it like an extra
segment type of thing that we will have
ever produced when it's done when it's
done it's gonna be really really gonna
be an hour-plus content right oh
absolutely absolutely so help us get
there okay 2100 is very doable whether
you contribute a dollar or five or ten
or a hundred
it's a patron goal of 2,100 patrons so
any contribution gets us closer more on
this hopefully very very soon